les venu le temps des quartiers
le flamand dont vous attrape en pleine
célébration du 20e anniversaire de notre
dame de paris qu'est ce que ça signifie
pour nous ben ça alors là je n'ai dû
être déjà
je
tél
c'est agréable parce que ça continue ça
ça va être pas on va encore être là pour
fêter accord va être je crois
et là pour toujours
à chaque fois c'est un miracle on est on
s'attendait pas à ce qu'une chanson
comme bell pouvait être un tube
souvent
quand
[Musique]
on était complètement là c'est comme
starmania l'a fait terminer à la période
du disco on était complètement à côté de
la plaque
[Musique]
qui aurait dit que sauf tourner le monde
du stand et pourrait être vite jantes et
dans les chaumières
c'est tout
à préparer cette entrevue je me suis
posé la question suivante pourquoi je
mets autant de chansons je pensais à
coeur de rockeur est arrêté par julien
clerc
[Musique]
suite
presque dans toutes mes chansons
personnage qui parle à la première
personne ou alors qu'un personnage que
je raconte mais je raconte mon avis
j'écris pas magie avec dix ans du soin
de vue beaucoup de plaisir parce que le
s'accaparer de tout ça de tous ces
personnages là et elle jouait les
personnes âgées elle avait pas besoin
des jouets et les vives et 6 c'était
extraordinaire c'est une très grande
interprète comme il y en a plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'autre jour au dépanneur à outremont
jeu madame avec enfants fourrure qui
débarque de sa limousine et elle rentre
dans l'épicerie et se retourner en
marcatel me vois qu elle le dit à
monsieur plamondon vous avez enchanter
nos vies c'est beau cadeau
la tête qui tourne
une question piège mais je m'amuse et le
plamandon quels sont selon vous vos
chansons les plus réussis c'est sûr si
on demande la plus belle je pense que
c'est c'est le monde est stone parce que
c'est une chanson qui on sait pas
comment elle est faite de
[Musique]
les chansons de starmania c'est quelque
chose de tout
[Musique]
cette année plus haut après mais après
je me suis amusé à faire beaucoup de
chansons pour justement pour julien
clerc pour toi ton de manas twachtman
pour charlebois etc
[Musique]
et en le clamant dans quelle est la
suite pour vous loger en train de faire
une comédie musicale depuis dix ans que
je travaille là dessus de sur des
musiques de schubert bon ben ce sera
peut-être le prochain
on sait qu'un organe mots qui m'a dit
kim embarquer là dedans et puis donc il
est dû au jour je m'en vais dans des
ordres de sa dépêche toi j'en ai une
autre est caché et qui met ça c'est sera
pour plus tard c'est une comédie
musicale qui se passe dans l'oeil de la
moitié dans le monde
amérindienne
moi j'ai une un centre urbain mon
arrière grand mère
c'est en 90 quand j'ai commencé je sois
plus hinault et puis ya eu la crise
d'oka tu as fait qu'on pouvait plus
faire ce sujet date est sûr qu'il faut
il faudrait le faire avec des vrais les
réseaux total mais là on perd la page
hésité à mettre ça sur la glace pour le
moment on verra le planant merci
beaucoup